you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game so let's see what we got
already I feel like I am always know
let's not play let's play g3 like I'm
always behind on the clock whenever I
play these five-o games can we pick up
the speed here
let's get c4 in so we have a cattle and
on board black does not want to take all
right let's go 92 I am prepared to
recapture with the night
maybe the pond will see just trying to
complete queenside development now fiend
cut out double fee and keto setup
let's get another move in Queen c2 rook
d1 on b5 I'll keep the tension
interesting could take with the night or
the pond
let's take with the night improve him
maybe he jumps into e5 and now I'll
throw my phone up to e4 no idea what
that Bishop is doing
let's give him a boo he goes too far I
jump into d6 let's put my rook here
first I'd like to hold off maybe on e4
my bishop may want to see you know what
let's put my knight here I'm working
with the space advantage so I'm gonna be
a pest I'm going to avoid too many
exchanges I have the time to do these
types of moves the position tells me
that this is not a sharp position just
yet I want to make sure these two brakes
do not happen let's get one more piece
playing
and I don't see five should be a giant
bother I did not say this yet but I held
off on b4 because I was afraid of a 5
let's jump into c5 right now Bishop
takes they gave me the bishop hair and a
little bit of space maybe I could let's
try this move actually instead of b4
what about a bishop on a5 no there's a
queen and rook here yeah that could be a
great bother on a knight move to d5 I'll
go here I could kick him away soon this
Knight cannot be shoot away so easily
let's give him a boot and now I think
I'm winning the knight has to go back to
b6 and they're just in a giant pickle Oh
a timely b6 is that really working
though
let's do a little bit of calculation
here
at night on d5 doesn't have any squares
if I go here there's Knight takes e4 I
could take and then take take that sort
of stuff but what if my knight simply
goes back to a4 where does he go I have
to play b5 that my knight returns to
this square I think I prefer that I
think in both cases I'll be better but I
see this as much more clear because this
is a huge weakness they could take this
pawn actually maybe in some line maybe
that's what they're gonna go for it's
probably the best chance having a
getting a rook and two pawns and I'll
get two minor pieces yeah I totally
missed that they could take a three
let's see if they go for it I think here
it's just
well I guess they didn't see that idea
they had to play b5 there well let's
just scoop up the night and let's hit
the bishop right back so they have two
pawns I have a minor piece who's not
playing
let's get him working actually I'm
getting two pieces working with that
last move my knight
and my bishop he could probably go
elsewhere he's observing a seven
excuse me a six and my other book to see
six her pointed see six at least
I'm also targeting f7 let's put the
Brooke here this might be too much I'm
going to cash out
mm-hmm
pinned okay
let's just drop back I want to secure
here I'm in a pin as well okay maybe my
rook wants to go to b1 expecting some
Queen move
where will she be
well placed I think in the end if
there's a couple captures and my queen
is here okay well let's get out of this
pin let's also notes
hmm
it's there better move what about bishop
c3 yeah maybe bishop c3 is better
because you know what I think this
should be seven in the ready to take my
knight and then take here the Queen is
unprotected you think Bishop c3 is
better maybe here is bests mmm Wow what
a weird position
alright I'm gonna go here
I think they could win upon they're not
going for that and now is this that has
the smoke finally cleared both right
around two minutes okay
can I now just take here and both seem
pretty good
which one should I go for hmm let me go
with that one take a sinner pond that
was tempting as well
not threatening to take the bishop
this night as a good home on b4 okay if
I move my queen
let's go let's go here actually maybe
Bishop h3
hitting the Queen no not quite
hmm
okay I think I need to reposition my
knight
maybe I jump into d6 I want to keep my
knight here okay I could take this pond
there on my knight though it's tension
between the bishops
a minute left let's take the bishop and
that was a bad move
okay if I play tonight c4
five
there was such a clean much more clean
approach than the one I am taking right
here that is for sure I'm very happy
with how I'm playing right now they did
a good job complicating that is for sure
I should be the one in my opponent's
camp this night is a tremendous bother
they have a pond for the piece three
versus one on the queenside
let's get this night here maybe I start
to finally coordinate a little bit put
the other night on f3 clean has a
responsibility she's not a fan of
defending the night's finally take let's
get this right playing threatening c5
but there on this night's let's just go
here crash through on c5 soon let's do
it
slight edge on the clock
they still need a flight square
resigned
Ignatian just rent things we're ready to
enter into bullet mode there anything
could have happened really upset with
how I played this game at this point
right here let's see right here let's
see
this moment this is you know I'm going
back reflecting on the game this is the
one position that's capturing high
tension what could I have done better
here to not allow these complications
because I probably allowed at some stage
I probably allowed black
have something like i mean when i
retweeted the night here as mentioned
they could maybe go on for this i take
the night they take the rook i take back
and in the ends I mean what just
happened there they took a rook and two
pawns and I have two minor pieces
probably something close to equal but I
want something cleaner so what is the
cleaner approach here so before I look
at this with the engine what could I
have done better
should I just chopped the night I take
the night they take my nights and then
how about I just take on e6 take on a
take upon and then threatened to take
another one I think I end up at just
being up upon yeah I should just take
the night take on these six and then
take on c5 I'm up upon and it's clean so
putting this on board I take I gotta
take back I take this way if they want
to do this will I take here with check
they'll probably recapture with upon I
take here and this is the position we
work with now if there's one downside
I'm seeing well if there's one strong
point in blacks position I would say
it's this point here the d5 square but
I'm off of huh and there won't be a
night arriving in my house
it's bad enough if a night is somewhere
here in the game he got to d3
he's an octopus from there he's a killer
okay yeah if I could do it over again
that's the variation I would go with if
I had more time to really think it
through this is the this is the cleaner
approach to take on d5 maybe their
computer will correct me but it seems
much more clean
and yeah I probably allowed some counter
chances so let me bring up the engine
and we'll have a look at it okay let us
see about this one cattle and they do
not take on C form instead C 692
I think it's fine this setup they'll be
a couple different approaches I guess at
least and see anything wrong with the
moves I'm making each or excuse me a six
odd
I'm not sure what the point of that is
b5 I would just sit I would hold off on
making any captures play Queen c2 so
they could probably do without that b6
Bishop b7 is probably the way forward
for black what happened in the game that
I've really struggled to do anything so
that's really and if there's a way to
improve on the black end that's one
thing I could say probably get this guy
working straight away do things that
facilitate his development b6 Bishop to
d7 I'm just slowly improving I could
probably go both ways here pawn or
Knight but seeing a moment to improve my
knight by a couple ranks and end up in
these
key 16 areas both of my nights are here
so this is the area ideally both nights
would like to be in the game so they're
there I mean eyeing up e5 I guess that
was to provoke a three
but uh yeah I think black from here is
really in trouble I mean look at the
evaluations even material but
have too many good pieces I have spaced
a lead in development and soon a strong
pawn Center efore d4
so the improvements are already in the
past year for black good another piece
working once again with the e4 it's fine
with this as I think it was right around
this point yeah I was saying I have the
time to maneuver this is a very
controlled position I'm controlling the
to keep on brakes you have blacks to
keep on brakes c5 and E 5 and I have
more space so I wanted to avoid a night
exchange play this position with all
four minor pieces in other words
so I'm lying up the c-5 square and I
guess let's just bring it to this point
well okay this may seem a little bit I
was saying I want to avoid peace
exchanges this is a moment where black
could take out my night but this is
that's an imbalanced that would be
giving up a bishop for night that would
be giving up blacks more important of
the two bishops if they're taking out my
night like this and I could take with
the pond and he becomes a monster and
this one squared e5
can be taken away so this would not be
good this is huge for Team white
dark square weaknesses in blacks camp
everywhere d6 b6 you know it's not
something to do so they have to try and
work around that night II for it
suggests this is where I now had the
idea to get my Bishop to a5 Knight B to
d5 I dropped my bishop back to e 1 which
is fine and now it does want to go with
b6 okay they drop the bishop back first
and now I played efore does likey form
and now I guess best is b6 the move they
played night to b6 and yeah this is just
game over because how do you ever get
out of this pin
you know you could defend like this but
my other night can come over here and
attack the pinch piece this would be way
too much
so they were right they probably
anticipated Bishop to a5 that's why they
went with b6 and what could I have done
better it suggests the move that I
played in the game night a4 let me just
see if this is fine as well
takes takes doesn't want to take on e6
c6 it wants to go with I was pointing
out east six and I guess either is fine
hmm prefers to take on c6 yeah getting a
passed pawn in here there's probably an
issue the knight jumping into c6 you
know okay so in this variation I was
pointing out just after the game before
looking at the engine I could take like
that and then it's better to take on c6
instead of e6 oh here's another train of
thought if I'm taking on e6 I'm I mean
I'm going to be up upon
either way but if I take in this
direction I'm helping this bishop play
if I take like this he still struggles
he's staring at his own pawns
so I should taken away where at least
I'm not helping facilitate blacks
development see what I was doing just
then was I was too focused on material I
was like okay I'm gonna be winning upon
but how about I win upon and not help my
opponent develop I didn't see that I
didn't think of it like that but yeah
makes make sense now
take on c6 just trying to identify the
differences just then okay well I played
in Knight a forum it suggested Bishop
takes a three now or even b5 he took on
e4 and I take they take rook a one it's
winning for me but it got way too
complicated
was there any opportunity here for team
black let's go at that for mmm
okay it wants to just maintain the night
here yeah okay that would have saved me
a lot of trouble because I won't have
had to worry about
add another the bishop hitting my rook
you know FF for just secure the night
even likes b4 here
then consider b4 I just got my night out
of the way I felt like he was losing my
phone was trying to undermine support of
e5 so just wanted to get him out of
harm's way but I gave up a little bit
something with that it does like Bishop
c3 Queen to e2 bishop veto I guess it's
still winning I take like this you know
I was torn in the game which pawn to
take here but I guess it's still winning
anything it just seems scary okay I
guess it was always winning but right
around this point yeah it's not fun
having to work around that night and it
seems to still be a winning advantage
throughout anything missed No
I guess not it seemed a little scary but
I guess there wasn't really any
opportunity that black had and well they
just resigned at this point it is plus
five and actually I'm just up a full
night at this stage I thought in the
game they would have just captured on b3
and we would go from here
Rick's e6 I was planning that I didn't
know what I was going to do after let's
say queen v8 but yeah I am up a knight
actually e6 is a move once rook c6 is in
there the Queen isn't stopping this
advance I could go with east six and now
Knight jumps in here and a rook on the
seventh I already have a flight square
okay
all right well interesting game
my opponent ended up a bit cramped they
didn't really solve their well they
didn't really complete development there
with that Queen Bishop and had some
space and I was a bit too cramping for
team white in that one all right
well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
any Catalan fans I don't play that too
often but a good opening anyhow
feel free to leave any feedback in the
comments section below and hope you're
having a great day take care bye
you
[Music]